and the emmy goes to shit's creek
eugene levy shits creek
catherine o'hara shits creek annie
murphy shit's creep
daniel levy shits free
andrew savadino daniel levy shits creek
daniel levy
shits creek
my goodness oh my goodness this tents on
fire
shit's creek swept at the 2020 emmy
awards on sunday night
oh no okay the internet's about to turn
on me i'm so sorry
wow wow wow thank you uh members of the
uh
uh television academy for nominating me
alongside these very cool women and for
topping off this fun evening with this
trophy
treat our show at its core is about the
transformational effects of love
and acceptance and that is something
that we need more of now than we've ever
needed before
what's going on this just felt like the
perfect place to ask you to marry me
are you sure easiest decision in my life
shit's creek ended after six seasons
earlier this year and was barely on the
emmy's radar during its run
until it won its first and only emmy in
2019
for outstanding comedy series i think in
showing up to these award shows i never
think we're nominees
i somehow feel like we've like snuck in
and are
taking advantage of an opportunity but
no we're actually nominated people
thought we were good yeah it was a slow
start but we didn't know it was a slow
start to anything
we were just having fun doing the show
our fan base
really became quite rabid and
i really credit them
with getting the word out on this show
shit's creek nabbed nine wins out of its
record-breaking
15 nominations the most ever wins and
nominations for a comedy series in its
final season
sweeping all four acting categories the
first time
a single comedy series has done that in
the emmy's
72 year history it is absolutely
incredible i think my dad
said it best um earlier tonight that it
feels like a dream that you just don't
want to wake up from to be perfectly
honest
and that's really how it's felt for all
of us it still feels very
strange um but what an
absolutely unbelievable way to end our
series i don't think you could ever ask
for a better conclusion to a story than
than tonight so uh we are absolutely
thrilled
in addition to the acting awards shit's
creek took home outstanding directing
for a comedy series
outstanding writing for a comedy series
outstanding contemporary costumes
outstanding casting for a comedy series
and the big one
outstanding comedy series i cannot
believe what is happening tonight i am
just i feel so incredibly lucky to have
been a part of this and to see
all of my favorite people win and
and express themselves in such a
gorgeous way i'm
i'm overwhelmed i cannot believe it i
hope there's a movie
i need the job what is your favorite
season
[Music]
awards